hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is David I Smith I'm a professor in the
Department of Laboratory Medicine and
pathology at the Mayo Clinic and I'll be
talking today about the history of first
generation next-generation sequencing
technologies the person who's going to
follow me Jonah score lock is this chief
scientific officer of Pacific
Biosciences and he's going to talk about
a long Reed sequencing technology all of
sequencing basically got started with
the development of Sanger sequencing
there were chemical sequencing methods
that were in use before this but it was
Sanger based sequencing which is
illustrated here that was really the
birth of the ability to sequence more
than very short stretches of DNA with
Sanger sequencing in the first
generation you do four separate
reactions each with a different
diagnostic nucleotide to terminate the
chains at each of the A's C's GS and T's
you run the separate lanes and then by
reading up the lanes you could ascertain
the sequence however the real advance
and what made this a possibility for
capturing something as large as the
sixth gigabase human genome we needed
the development of automated DNA
sequencers and this was sort of a 1999's
the penultimate Sanger based sequencer
the ABI 3700 and this machine was a 96
capillary electrophoresis machine that
each time it ran was capable of
generating 75 kilobases of DNA sequence
with the vision of craig Venter this is
actually a room inside Celera genomics
which was a private company that he was
at the head of and this shows a room
with 330 of these ABI sequencing
machines and this became the powerhouse
whereby it was possible to sequence the
DNA of none other than craig Venter now
the cost to actually sequence the first
genome was about three billion dollars
once you had all the machines and
everything in place it's about 200
million for reagent costs the reason for
this is twofold the first is that you
had to clone individual
pieces into e.coli to make many copies
you actually needed about 10 to the 13th
copies to do the Sanger sequencing the
second reason is that each individual
reaction was 10 microliters and when you
have to do millions of these the overall
cost of these two together is expensive
so the question is how can we bring
genome sequencing to the masses
how can you dramatically decrease the
cost of genome sequencing and of course
it raises the question how much for a
genome before it becomes a part of
standard clinical practice for many
years while this was ramping up there
was the thought and the push that the
thousand-dollar genome would be a great
target but even that was a phenomenal
improvement in technology because you
had to go from something that cost three
billion dollars to reduce it down to a
thousand dollars but in order to even
start on that journey and actually I'm
going to tell you by the end of today
that we may have exceeded and been able
to do a genome for even less than a
thousand dollars but in order to make
this work you had to solve the two major
problems of capillary electrophoresis
sequencing and that was the cloning of
each individual fragment into a
bacterial plasmid and then the use of
lots of reagents for sequencing so the
first thing is how can one replace the
cloning and it turns out there are three
main strategies that have been utilized
two of them are PCR based the first is
called bridge amplification and I'll
show you slide of that the second is
called emulsion PCR however there's a
third strategy that does not rely on PCR
pcr tends to put in artifacts during the
amplification process so this is a non
PCR based strategy which is linear
amplification using a 529 polymerase
where the pieces are cloned into a nano
viral vector and it produces rolling
circles to make copies however one of
the problems with each of these is they
produce different amounts of amplify
template and you need a platform that
can sequence those limited number of
molecules so a clonal application by
emulsion PCR is shown here what happens
here is that if you emulsify water in an
oil mixture you will produce very tight
water droplets that are immersed in the
oil if you do that process and Sonic
eight but in the presence of very tiny
beads so they can be of different size
sizes the beads and a certain
concentration you will generate water
droplets that contain a tiny bead in
them now these beads are coated with
Aligarh nucleotides that are actually
complementary to all ago nucleotides
that you place on the ends of all of the
DNA fragments that you would like to
sequence shown on the top left so when
you Sonic eight all of these together at
a very low concentration of DNA these
beads are small enough that you can have
hundreds of millions of them in a
Stinney micro centrifuge tube and even
if only one in a hundred of the beads
has a piece of DNA you can amplify that
piece of DNA on that beet and millions
of them in this tiny little tube the
beads that have amplified DNA can then
be purified from the beads that do not
by Grady intentions
since centrifuge gradient centrifugation
and you can purify the beads that have
amplified DNA the second technique a
technique that does not require this
order wire water mixture is known as
bridge amplification and is this
illustrated here in this instance
instead of coating the surface of a bead
with oolagah nucleotides that are
complementary to all ago nucleotides
that you're going to put on the end of
the DNA fragments the Allah bows are
actually on the surface of something
that is known as a flow cell the DNA
fragments are then ylabel are then place
so they have complement y'all are gonna
knock the tights at the end of all of
those fragments and then you denature
them and you flow the DNA fragments as
shown in the top middle slide across the
surface of the slide one end of the
oligonucleotide will find its complement
and then you'll have a piece of DNA
sticking up when its base paired down at
one end however the other end has all
your nucleotides that are also
complementary to other alga nucleotides
on the surface of the flow cell so it's
shown on the top right you can actually
produce a tiny little bridge that how so
has a template and a primer and this is
what you need and it's ideal for DNA
polymerase to make us
copy that's shown on the bottom left if
you denature that fragment now you have
two fragments that are complements of
each other if you repeat this process
about 30 times where there was
originally a single DNA fragment there
will now be a cluster of about 30,000
and on the bottom right you can see that
there is a whole series of clusters on
the surface of the slide this has many
advantages over the emulsion PCR the
simplicity of it and the the lack of
meeting to do the very messy oil-water
emotions and the purification that comes
afterwards the third technique is again
this adenoviral technique where the tiny
DNA fragments are inserted into a nano
viral vector and then a 5:29 polymerase
rolls around the circle to make copies
now interestingly this one produces the
least number of copies you get about 300
copies of the DNA from each individual
DNA fragment those 300 copies compressed
down to something which is called a nano
ball or a DnB and these nano balls can
then be deposited into a surface upon
which DNA sequencing will be performed
now in addition to the techniques to
amplify the DNA and this is all for the
first generation next generation
sequencing there were the next thing was
how to reduce reaction volumes because
the 10 micro reactions that are done in
capillary electrophoresis use
considerable amounts of reagents so
there's different strategies there are
strategies where you can put coasters on
a slide surface and that was really
illustrated with the bridge
amplification that I showed you two
slides back the second strategy is to
have small beads either on a slide
surface or within wells and these of
course are the beats that have been done
with emulsion PCR and all of this comes
together with something which we're now
trying to call instead of
next-generation sequencing even though
that is its name massively parallel
sequencing RMPs because that's what all
of these are these are technologies that
do sequencing on a massive scale and
basically for example the very first
generation that I'll show you in a
second where the the sequencing missed
Piko titer plate which contained
one-and-a-half million Wells so the very
first next-generation sequencer was
developed by a company 454 and their
first machine was called the GS 24 the
genome sequencer 20 because it was
capable of doing 20 mega bases of DNA
sequence each time you ran the machine
which was dramatic improvement over the
75 kilobases on the ABI 3700 this is how
the machine works again on the left side
you sort of see how the emulsion PCR
amplifies the individual DNA fragments
on a B in the bottom middle the beads
that are purified can then be deposited
into the wells and then on the bottom on
the right that this entire thing is set
up in such a way that the beads
themselves are now coated with the
enzymes that are needed for pyro
sequencing the nuclei end and the
basically what you then do is you flood
the entire Piko titer plate first with
and the a nucleotide and you ask the
question is there an incorporation in
any of the wells which will be seen as a
flash of light because of the enzymes
from pyro sequencing you then follow up
with the next nucleotide one after the
other now on this right side of this
slide you see the first generation
sequence that can be determined with
this platform and it shows both the
strengths and the weaknesses of the
platform because the one of the
strengths is it's a relatively long read
191 base pairs however what you can see
is the incorporations that occur if
there's a single base a single a that
will be incorporated but if there are
two A's or two T's or whatever both will
be incorporated and you get a slightly
larger signal if there are and you can
see this on the top left if there are
four G's you get a signal that's about
four times the size this is fine if
you're discerning one two three or four
homopolymers in a row but if you're
sequencing something for a clinical
sample sometimes homopolymers can be 10
or 15 long and this machine cannot
discern the difference between 10 and 11
12 and 13 etc so the strengths and the
way
this was very long reads actually the
191 base period I showed you on the
previous slide was increased to over 400
base pairs and actually by the time this
machine was fully mature it was capable
of thousand base pairs of sequencing and
there were improvements in machine but
the weaknesses remain the emulsion PCR
the fact that the nucleotides themselves
are not blocked so if you get a homo
polymer stretch you can't determine this
determinant sequence and the last one
was even though this machine did improve
25 fold in its lifetime there was
limited Headroom for further increases
beyond a 25 improvement and remember
we're trying to improve DNA sequencing
to reduce the cost of three billion
dollars to below $1000 so increments of
25 or are not good enough we need two
things to improve a thousandfold or even
greater the second major platform that
was developed was the Illumina genome
analyzer and this is the first
generation machine from that this
machine used basically the bridge
amplification that I showed you before
with all of its advantages as compared
to emulsion PCR then once you have the
various clusters on the slide the second
improvement with this a very important
improvement in this platform is that
each of the nucleotides has a different
fluorescent floor attached to it and the
floor is attached in such a way that
only a single nucleotide can be added at
a time so you flood all four of those
with labelled nucleotides across the
flow cell surface and you ask what is
the first nucleotide which has been
incorporated you take a picture and that
is shown on the top right the next
reaction is a chemical reaction that
chemically Cleaves the fluorescent group
from each of the single bases that have
been added and now it is capable of
adding a second base and you repeat the
process one base addition at a time you
take a picture of that and that is
thrown in the second thing on the right
hand side and since you know the x and
y-coordinates of every single cluster
the reading of the sequences the
positioning of that cluster so for
example for the one that's on the far
left the actual sequence of the first
four bases our five is GC TGA the first
five bases so
that is how the sequencing is performed
now this platform had dramatic advances
the first generation genome analyzer was
capable of a Giga base of sequence so it
was actually better than the 454 at the
best that it could possibly be but what
it generated this by making sequence
from 48 million clusters 48 million
separate DNA molecules that are
amplified but the Reed Lance were quite
short they were only 31 base pairs
however over the next three years the
platform increased its output by doing
two things figuring out how to get
greater numbers of clusters on the slide
surface and increasing the read length
and once the read length increased
beyond 100 base pairs you didn't have
any of the same problems that you had
with these very short reads that it was
originally capable of the second
generation of machine from Illumina was
the hi-c 2000 this is shown here this
made some dramatic improvements and that
grew much greater output but eventually
with this type of platform and this is
shown on the bottom right you generated
so many clusters on the flow cell
surface which is shown on the top left
that it becomes very difficult to
discern one sequence cluster from
another and then the next advance is
shown on the bottom left which is to not
just have a flat flow cell surface but
to have a pattern flow cell technology
and basically what you do here is the
DNA molecules that are amplified are
actually amplified in the well itself if
you see the bottom middle picture that
shows the type of signal that you see
with the same density as the one on the
bottom right but it's so much easier to
discern what's going on in individual
ones and it has greater capability for
increasing this by simply decreasing the
diameter of each of the individual wells
the instrument performance that has
happened on this platform has been
dramatic when this started 2007 that on
the GA this machine was capable of a
Giga base and on the left-hand side
that's 200 and 400 Giga bases of
sequence output you could barely see it
by the time the GA was retired it had
increased its output to 80 Giga bases
the high seek the next Jenner
started at 200 Giga bases was almost
capable of 400 but with the improvements
in the pattern flow cells they were able
to crack the tera base of sequence
output today the penultimate currently
no Illumina sequencing machine is shown
here this is the Nova seek 6000 this
machine is capable of running go back a
slide this machine is capable of running
three different sizes of flow cells
their highest output flow cell is
capable of generating six tera bases of
sequence output so every time you run
this machine it produces six Tara bases
of sequence alpha this is an improvement
from it less than a Giga base to sixth
error basis is a 6000 fold improvement
on this single platform now there are a
couple of other competing platforms one
of them is a company that's called ion
torrent and ion torrent there's a
completely different type of sequencing
they do sequencing on a tiny little chip
that looks almost identical to computer
chip because that's indeed how it's made
what the ion torrent chip however is
instead of an electronic computer chip
instead shown on the bottom right is
basically a bunch millions of tiny
little wells but each well is a sense or
they're linked up and tied to basically
a pH meter and it's important because
every single time a nucleotide is
incorporated a hydrogen ion is released
so basically if you amplify DNA
molecules on beads very similar to the
beads from the 454 but smaller you can
basically do the exact same thing that
you do with 4 or 5 or sequencing but
instead of using the enzymes you know to
see the emission of light instead you're
gonna look for the change in pH so then
by putting this all together basically
you flow a C G and T unblocked
nucleotides across it and if one is
incorporated and this is shown on the
right you're going to see a change in pH
in that well that will be an indication
that that base has been incorporated
there are a couple of different versions
of this the very original one on the top
left is the PGM the personal genome
machine the one in the middle is the
second generation they already have a
third generation us and they are
evolving now there are weaknesses to
this platform that are identical to its
weaknesses on the 454 platform they're
almost the same except for how they
detect the bases themselves and those
weaknesses are the emulsion PCR the
homopolymers the fact that as they try
to play catch-up to terms of the output
to the on the Illumina chain they're not
able to do that their output is a
fraction of what could be obtained on
the Illumina machine and right now
Illumina really controls the sequencing
space somewhere in the range of 90% of
the sequencing that's in across the
planet is done on that platform now
there are strengths to the ion torrent
platform one has a quick turnaround time
faster than the Illumina platform
there's a lower input amount of DNA
necessary for selection protocols and
for this reason a couple of years ago
the National Cancer Institute actually
chose the personal genome sequencing
platform over the my seat the Illumina
sequencer because they could get more
signal with less amount of input DNA
there's also viable solutions to
simplify emulsion PCR it's called the
ion chef which is an automated machine
that does those things and has a
flexible output now the total cost of
NGS turns out to not just be a single
thing of DNA sequencing but is a series
of things the first is the library
preparation and of course depending on
the type of library you may there are
different prices actually the simplest
library preparation of all is whole
genome sequencing some of the other ones
are actually more complex and end up
being quite a lot more expensive now
sequencing is the second cost and this
also depends on what you're doing if
you're trying to sequence an entire
genome a human genome you need to do
about a hundred Giga bases of sequencing
however if you're trying to sequence a
small gene panel you need a fraction of
that
now the third major cost this analysis
and this is a huge bottleneck of this
entire technology because there are a
lot of things that are involved in the
analysis
depending on what you're trying to see
and there are still need for improvement
in this area and the very last one it's
probably the most significant but yet is
one people rarely even consider is the
cost for storing this data so when
you're saying how much does it cost or
what is the target for example in
bringing a whole genome sequencing down
to a cost you have to realize that all
of these must be added together it can't
just be a thousand dollars for the
sequencing and then ten thousand for
everything else
now whole genome sequencing is an
extremely powerful tool to examine
changes across the genome it detects
point mutations but it also detects copy
number variations translocations and
deletions but there are problems with
with it even though the novus seek has
truly cracked the cost for sequencing
below a thousand dollars actually the
cost for a hundred Giga bases of
sequencing on an OVA seek is only 375
bucks but again as I just mentioned
before that's just a sequencing cost how
much does it cost for analysis very
important question is finding
alterations that are actionable because
the reality is that less than two
percent of the genome actually codes for
protein and only a fraction of the
proteins that may have any any
alterations do we actually have
something that we can treat based upon
that and the other issue is the overall
turnaround time so what will it take for
whole genome sequencing to take off to
take off first this depends upon which
patients are getting whole genome
sequencing are we talking about cancer
care and treatment are we talking about
the entire populations however whether
you whichever one you are talking about
the total cost must come down
can we bring library prep costs under
$50 can we bring sequencing to add
around $100 and what about an analysis
and interpretation so I think that the
real goal it doesn't have to actually be
achieved but it is something that is a
game changer and how you think about it
is what if a genome only costs $100 cost
all in that would be a phenomenal target
that would be transformational now there
is a problem when we live in a little
in a sequencing world when a single
company has such a strong monopoly
because the lack of competition does not
serve a scientific or clinical community
reagent costs can remain high there's no
reason for them to reduce those costs
the customer service doesn't have to be
as good as if they had a competition and
felt that they had to treat their
customers better but how to bring down
the cost of whole genome sequencing
further there's a lack of motivation
unless Illumina believes they have some
competition and I believe they might
there is company known as BGI the
Beijing genome Institute and they have a
bunch of million genome initiatives the
Beijing genome Institute is now housed
in Shenzhen China they are also the cng
be the China National gene bank so it
contained within the the the BGI
Institute in Shenzhen is this very large
depository of samples and they have
plans to do a million human genomes
millions of plant and animal genomes and
as many bacterial and viral genomes as
they can their platform is based upon a
technology developed by a company called
Complete Genomics again they use the
nano balls to amplify the DNA to 300
copies and these these 300 copies form
these tiny little balls which can be
deposited in the you can see this on the
bottom right onto a pattern surface you
can have so many you can have hundreds
of millions of these nano balls across
the slide surface and then these can be
done with a combinatorial probe method
for doing sequencing the next slide
actually shows their machine which has
just been produced and is now being made
available in several places around the
world this is the t7 this is a machine
which can generate seven tera bases of
DNA sequence per run now what's
important about all of these things is
that today BGI can do whole genome
sequencing and this is what they charge
when you send samples to them and this
is library prep sequencing analysis of
600 dollars but they're planning on the
t7 to bring the cost of 200 dollars by
the end of 2019 and
they're making and setting up plans to
develop a bigger factory scale sequencer
where they could bring the cost of whole
genome sequencing down to just a hundred
dollars this is a big thing so
competition is good as BGI ram ster is
providing $100 coastal and genome
Illumina will have no choice but to
compete and we've seen a reduction in
whole genome sequencing from 3 billion
dollars to $600 in just 19 years so it
is it possible to get to $100 genome is
it possible to think even that we could
get to a 10 dollar genome now how will
the hundred dollar genome be a
game-changer for $100 whole genome
sequencing will replace small gene
panels and even whole exome sequencing
because those technologies actually cost
more just to capture the DNA than $100
genomes could be sequence at or before
birth and then whole genome sequencing
could be the clinical test for cancers
now if the full genome only costs $100
that's not the only use that you can do
for DNA sequencing but when the genome
does cost that little all the other uses
for DNA sequencing next-generation
sequencing
like sequencing small gene panels
transcriptomes and anything else you
wanted to also cost less so this drives
the cost of all these technologies to
lower prices so what are the problems
well what does our genome sequence tell
us what good will whole genome
sequencing be for a healthy population
and will there be health coverage
discrimination these are important
concerns but the reality is then this is
an estimate and I'm fully expecting that
I will underestimate that there is it's
been quoted that 50 million fully
sequenced genomes will occur by 2022 so
whether you think these problems are big
problems are insurmountable problems the
reality is that we're going to have a
large number of people sequenced now
everything that I've been discussing is
short read sequencers the Illumina
sequencer does sequences of pieces that
about 250 to 300 base pairs the problem
that you keep the reason that you cannot
sequence longer is that because you
amplify the templates when you're
incorporating a base you don't always
get
100% incorporation and when you repeat
this over a 100 iterations what happens
is the templates go out of phase and the
signal strength decreases and you can no
longer discern what is the next base
added and it's quite difficult to
assemble a human genome that's 45
percent highly repetitive sequences with
200 to 300 base pair pieces in reality
what you're doing is you're generating a
map of the genome of individual pieces
so you can line that up against the
reference genome you're not at
generating integrated genome so the
other issue is that it's really
impossible to discern complex genomic
alterations for example those that are
current cancer and one last thing that I
don't even have on the slide is when
you're sequencing transcripts and
looking at transcript isoforms you can't
tell one isoform from another with short
reads however long we technologies could
do this and this is known as
second-generation massively parallel
sequencing and the idea behind it is to
develop technology to sequence single
molecules there are two currently
valuable platforms for doing this the
first is packed Biosciences Jonah's core
Locke who's the chief scientific officer
will follow my talk and talk about that
and the second is a company called
Oxford nanopore they use two different
technologies but they do the same type
of thing they generate sequences of
single unamplified molecules and because
of this and they're single molecules the
Reed lens that they're able to generate
they are very impressive in excess of
100,000 base pairs so I will stop there
and then Jonas will follow up to talk
about the second generation of these
types of sequencing thank you